when ryan popped the question to cassie
in 2019
the plan was always for a long
engagement
um he asked me out but they had no idea
of the worry that was in store
as they counted down to june now finally
there's hope
their wedding date is two days after the
restrictions should in theory
have been lifted um cassie looked to me
already and i said oh look forrest
announced we can have a full wedding
so i'm hopeful this month now we've had
the announcement we've spoken to the
venue
we have a little bit more security of
what we can do
the changes mean that from march the 8th
weddings will be able to go ahead with
six guests
the number will then rise to 15 people
on april the 12th
increasing again on the 17th of may this
time to 30.
and finally on june the 21st all legal
limits on numbers will be lifted
as long as the scientists say it's okay
it doesn't help joanna and paul here
they are at the church on postponed
wedding date number one last spring
then number two in december now the
couple who met as saint john ambulance
volunteers
have got to reschedule date number three
planned for april it's put us right back
to square one and we've obviously got to
run the gauntlet of contacting all the
suppliers as we've done
twice previously um with many of them
sort of saying oh well i'm already
booked up because there's
tens of thousands of people just like us
in exactly the same position having to
do this all over again
it's not just couples who've suffered
the wedding industry is on its knees
waiting to get going again and the
future of 60 000
businesses is at stake there's no doubt
here
this sector has been left behind we have
not had any support
and we've been prevented by the
restrictions from trading in
any commercially viable form for nearly
a year
and now we're told until the end of june
we must have that support
or our industry will collapse
there is at least a timetable now and
for ryan and cassie
it bodes well but come june they'll be
able to tie the knot as planned
emma birchley sky news